I'd like to welcome you
to today's webinar.
My name is Deena Vaneski, and
I will be your moderator.
Today, we will be talking about
leading innovation by design.
Bill is the Thomas Siebel Professor
of Business Leadership, Strategy, and
Organizations.
He's affiliated faculty at
the Woods Institute for the environment
here at Stanford, and he co-directs
the executive program in strategy and
organization that runs during the summer.
Bill studies competition among
organizations and how organizations and
industries evolve globally.
His prior research includes studies of how
strategic differences and strategic change
among organizations effect their growth,
performance and survival.
It's now my pleasure to turn
things over to Professor Barnett,
Bill thank you very much for
being here with us today.
>> Well, thank you, Dena and
thanks everyone for tuning in.
We'll be talking about innovation and
innovation by design
over the next hour many of
the ideas we talk about.
There is a great deal of research on in.
Rather than having me
go into that research,
I’ll often refer to my teaching notes
which I put out on a blog for your
reference should you want to take a look
at it, and here’s the address of that.
So, that way we don't have to go over
things that I've written about at length.
So, that's where I've put
all my teaching notes and
you can,
take a look there whenever you want.
And I guess while I'm plugging,
my teaching notes,
we could also talk about
where you can follow me.
On twitter,
which once again is Barnett talks.
So, let's talk about innovation by design
one of the things that we should
make clear first when we talk about
innovation by design is
that as a population
We are not good at predicting
the direction of dramatic change.
And that's not just true for,
people generally who maybe aren't experts.
That's especially true for experts.
When you look at the big changes that have
come along in systems of innovation over
the years, all over the world, we have
done a very bad job of predicting them.
So, take for example the world
wide web and the internet.
Today especially,
if you talk to people who are so
young that they've never known the world
without the internet, we can't imagine
life without the internet I know my kids
often in the middle of a conversation
will fact check on their smartphone,
in the middle of a conversation.
It's taken for granted that we can have
access to the world's information.
But if you go back to 1992,
1993, the very early days,
the internet existed, the world wide web
was just being created, in terms of a,
a massive system where Lots of
different computers could go in.
And then take content the way
that we now take for granted.
We have no understanding
of where that was going.
It's actually very interesting
that at the time our experts said
there was no need for the World Wide Web.
Including those who had invented
the technologies for the World Wide Web.
I remember Bruno De Leon
who was a French software
developer and
entrepreneur had created a company
based on a software that did
manipulation of photographs.
And back in 1992, 1993.
Bruno was a visitor in my class
on organizational growth,
and Bruno took the stage after we
talked about their technology,
and he talked about the future, and
he said, he envisioned a future.
Well lots of people would
go on to computers.
Not to use the computer, but to access
photographs from other people's computers.
Now, you hear that today and
you say, but of course.
Well I can tell you,
at the end of that class when I looked
at my class ratings, they were fine.
Except for the Billy on session.
And the students were convinced
that this guy was out of his mind,
and that we shouldn't be
having him back in again.
And yet, he was the one person
I remember from that era who
was actually talking about
the way we use computers today,
and when you go through the archives
as I have done, you find there
are very little understanding
of where technologies are going.
So, that's first thing I
think we have to get clear.
We aren't good at predicting innovation,
and
our experts are particularly not
good at predicting innovation.
But a second point to make when it
comes to understanding innovation
is that we're really good at
retrospectively rationalizing.
Once an innovation comes about,
we quickly realize collectively what
the meaning of an innovation is and
come to assume it, and obviously,
the web is an example of that.
We now take for granted that it exists,
but another great example are these
business school case studies that you
often read about successful companies.
They're often written up in a way that
seems so compelling, that the opportunity
was so clear, often the innovations
are talked about as if they were planned.
I was sitting on
University Avenue in Palo Alto,
enjoying the sunshine
a couple of weeks ago, and
I overheard a couple of people probably
in their 20s talking about Facebook.
Now, I've followed Facebook since
its beginning with case studies.
And, most people know about the road
that Facebook has followed to success as
being one that really emerged through lots
of different unexpected developments.
And yet, to hear them talk about Facebook,
the platform strategy,
the monetization model,
you would think that it had been
planned by a master chess player.
And it's that kind of retrospective
rationalization that we're so good at.
In a way, we look at companies often
the way we look at a persons career.
You know, a company's strategy
Is a lot like a person's resume.
It is a retrospective rationalization
of that company's life.
Just like a resume is a retrospective
rationalization of your career.
It's accurate, factually.
Your resume is accurate, but
there's nobody's life that
really reads like a resume.
I often joke that nobody's
resume Says moved to Boston for
girl, yet it happens all the time.
One of my sons did it.
I don't know if he's tuned in today
to the webinar, but ultimately he and
the girl married and so we have evidence
that that was why he moved to Boston.
His resume says something about Harvard.
That's the retrospective
rationalization of what happened.
And you can think of your
own resumes that way.
Now, I raise this topic of the resume and
rationalization and
retrospective rationalization of
businesses, not to be cynical, but
to be honest About the fact that
what unfolds makes sense to us only
in retrospect and as humans we are really
good at retrospectively rationalizing.
Not only that, it is our job as a leader
to retrospectively rationalize why
our firm wins or why our firm loses.
So I'm not cynical at all about
retrospective rationalization.
I just wanna point out that that's
what goes on in organizational life.
Now when you put these two facts together,
number one that we are not
good at predicting innovation.
And number two, that we are really
good at retrospectively rationalizing.
It creates a problem.
We tend to be very bad at organizing for
innovation.
And to explain my point here,
let me tell a story.
I remember going to Singapore in the late
90s to lecture on the same topic,
on organizing for innovation.
And as many of you may know,
Singapore as a system,
as a city-state, as a society,
is extremely good at planning.
And you only have to go through their
airport to enjoy the fruits of that.
I often wish that many of the other
airports of the world, would
outsource their operations to Singapore,
because Singapore is so good at planning.
As I'm there in Singapore, I noticed in
the mall that was by the Weston Hotel,
there was a street musician
playing a guitar, and
he was very clean had a poncho on.
It was air conditioned,
of course, being Singapore.
He was singing Peter, Paul and Mary songs.
Puff the Magic Dragon,
or something like that.
Now, all my education took
place in Berkeley, so
I know about street musicians.
On average, they don't sound that good.
They're not very pleasant, they often are
not someone you'd want to hang out with.
These Singapore street musicians
were actually very nice people,
they looked approachable and in fact,
there was a second one that I saw that
night in the lobby of the Shangri-La.
Now, at that point, I knew that
there was a pattern nothing happens
in Singapore by accident anyway,
never mind twice.
Well, come to find out, that the campaign
that was going on in Singapore that
year was to increase cre to increase
creativity and spontaneity.
And these street musicians
were part of that campaign.
Now think about this.
Let's think about the innovation process.
What's going on in the case
of the Singapore story?
Here's a distribution
of possible outcomes.
And you don't know what your gonna
get in the innovation process.
Some of your outcomes,
in fact, are very unpleasant.
So here's my technical symbol for that
some of them are gonna look like genius.
Later, and who knows what
the real distribution looks like.
Here I have most of our innovations
being sort of, in between.
And think of musicians, for example.
We want to have a musical
genius come out of a system.
We want to come up with
the next Neil Young or
Bob Dylan or
whoever you see as a musical genius.
But the system's going to give us lots
of riff raff along the way down here.
Well, Singapore looked at this problem,
they said,
we would like to have creativity.
So they managed it.
They know how to plan.
But in that planning, what do they do?
Here's the distribution of
outcomes they produced.
We are not gonna have any of
that foolishness first of all,
none of those avoidable street
musicians I used to see in Berkeley.
Uh-oh, the implications of that planning
is that neither will we
have genius over here.
In a sense,
the price of genius is foolishness.
When we manage the innovation process,
look what we do.
We manage away variance.
The key to innovation is variance.
Yet, most of our managerial systems,
right?
There's our variants.
Most of our managerial systems manage for
the mean in here.
And this is the problem
with managing innovation.
Especially given the way that
we retrospectively rationalize,
we think of course,
we can identify innovation.
But no, we only identify innovation after
we know the difference between
the fools and the geniuses.
And that only happens once we
allow variance to take place.
It's one of the biggest problems that we
face in the management of innovation,
is that we tend to manage away
the variance of the system.
Therefore, while we get no foolishness,
neither do we get genius.
So what do we do?
What are the implications of this?
Well it turns out,
we can manage to increase variance.
We can think about
increasing the variability
of what is produced by a system but
it requires a very different philosophical
approach to how we lead organizations.
And if I had to boil it down Deena,
I would boil it down to this following
statement, our job in leading
innovation is not to know the future.
Our job is to create the system
that discovers that future.
And that means creating organizations and
larger ecosystems of
organizations that have high variance
as one of their characteristics.
That produce lots of foolishness and
failure as the price we pay to
get those moments of genius.
Bill, we've had a bunch of questions
already about what you've been saying,
some about using models to look at
what's happened in the past and try and
predict what might happen in the future.
But then you just mentioned having
all these different ways of,
of innovating, I guess, doing different
work, so how do you, how do you do that?
>> Hm-mm.
>> How do you take an organization that
typically develops one or two products and
allow for that type of innovation or
innovative work?
>> Yes, now of course, there's a
tremendous amount of work on this, Deena,
with respect to the,
in managing the innovation process.
And I think if I had to boil it down,
especially when we're talking
about predictive models.
Remember every model predicts
a distribution of outcomes.
It, it has an on average prediction, but
it also has, if you will, a variance.
And so, in a way, our best models,
the ones that are most accurate,
are the ones that are,
in many ways, minimizing variance.
So ironically, while they'll do a very
good job of predicting those things in
the future that should follow from what
we've already experienced in the past.
Precisely for that reason,
they'll do a very bad job of
predicting completely new realities.
Let me give you an example.
I studied the evolution of
the computer industry in a,
in a book that I published
a few years ago.
I'm not plugging the book.
In fact, my wife describes it as a book
that was written not to be read.
So I'll sum up everything you
would ever wanna know out of that
book in the next minute.
And so don't bother with reading it.
But in looking at the history
of the computer industry.
The early firms, those in
the mainframe era, were tremendous
at modeling changes as they were taking
place in terms of the mainframe computer.
It wasn't just IBM,
there were a number of firms involved.
Tremendous amount of technological
expertise took us from the very
early computers through to computers that
were used in large scale industry and
government and military and so forth.
Now famously, and probably most of you
know this story, computing changed.
Coming into the 1960s,
moving into the 1970s and, and
into the 1980s, during During that period,
there was a shift towards what we now
talk about as distributed computing.
This is prior to the personal computer,
prior to the microcomputer.
A shift in the logic of computing.
If you do want to read about it actually,
the novel Soul of the New Machine is a,
is a great reference for that.
And many of the companies that were
starting up then began to use a new term.
The term was hacking and hacker.
There was a hacker code of of ethics.
That said computing should
be accessible to all.
That there should be a much more
distributed bottom up approach.
Now albeit the fact that most of
the people involved in that movement have
the largess of Stanford and
MIT at their disposal.
So, it wasn't quite a populist movement.
But nonetheless, the idea was that you
could access computers from a distributed
system, rather than through
a centralized mainframe system.
Well, it turns out that that logic,
everything about that logic of organizing,
competing, designing computers was so
different than anything that you could
imagine in the mainframe era, that all
those models of the development of
the mainframe computer, that emphasize
scale and economies of scale.
We're in a sense disrupted by this
movement to distributed computing.
The better you did at developing
the mainframe, the more inappropriate
was everything about what you did for
distributed computing.
And therefore,
the mainframe firms that tried to move
into distributed computing failed.
Now here's what's really
ironic about this.
Once the distributed computing firms
came to blossom the digital equipment
corporations data general, many of
these much storied innovative firms.
They were talked about then as the
obviously novel disruptive organizations.
Well, then along comes the microcomputer.
With the microprocessor, the microcomputer
is yet again another logic of computing
that was completely different
from the design characteristics
of distributed computing systems required
a different kind of organization,
much more focus on distribution, much more
of an inclusion of the general public and
retail markets, and so forth.
Completely different
approach to software design.
As late as the early 1980s,
in the Stanford library,
there still are compu- books on
the computer industry that dismissed
the microcomputer as a toy used for
trivial computing purposes.
Once again, a disruption had awry, had,
had come along, where our old logic
didn't apply to the new logic.
The old models weren't good at
predicting the new development.
The new developments were taking the world
in a completely different direction.
Now look, I bring up this example
not because it's exceptional.
These kinds of changes, these completely
unexpected transformations of
industry through innovation
happen across all industries, and
are happening at an increasing rate.
My point is that the models that predict,
because they're based on history,
are particularly bad at under,
at, at at, at predicting how these
innovations will take place.
The economy, and different economies
are better or worse at this, but
the economy allows for lots of variance.
And so
the high variance parts of the economy
are the parts of the economy that
come up with these innovations.
You know, many people come to Silicon
Valley in order to understand innovation.
And they will come from other countries.
They'll say we'd love to
have a Silicon Valley.
And the very first thing I say is well,
let's look at your failure rate.
And you often get surprised.
They say, "No we actually,
we prefer not to have failure.
We, we want to have innovation.
And I say, but of course.
But the best predictor of innovation,
which is genius, is whether or
not this system is allowing for failure.
Because that tells me it's
a high variance system.
And it's a high-variance system that
produces both genius and folly, and
typically upends the models that
were predictive in the past.
>> This is amazing.
We've had a lot of questions about that.
And first, someone was asking about,
you, can't you just respond quickly
to other changes that are going on?
But then when you look
at the technologies it,
it doesn't seem like you
could really keep up.
So it seems like you need to have
a large group of people working on lots
of different projects and so
can you talk a little bit about how you,
how do you do that?
How do you make it safe for
people to fail in a company
knowing that you have no idea what's
gonna happen in the future and
that one of those things might be
the new direction of your company?
>> That's a good a good question.
DNN it's, it's typically the one
that comes up at this point.
Once again there is a lot of work on this.
I guess to sum it up, I would say that
what matters most is knowing whether or
not you're trying to capitalize on
existing technologies, or whether or
not you're trying to move in directions
that are likely to be disruptive.
Because look, when we're, when we're
trying to capitalize on existing
technologies, we,
we need to focus on what is already known,
and plan for
time to market given those technologies.
Now let's talk about Seagate
as a great example of this.
When Steve Luczo initially took
over as CEO of, of Seagate, and
now I'm going way back to the late 90s
right around the turn of the the century
that company was a technological leader
that had been perennially unprofitable.
And when you look at why,
it had to do with the fact that it was
constantly lagging in time to market.
Well Steve shifted Seagate at that
time to a time to market strategy.
And the way he did that was to remind the
organization and really move the culture,
and structure and routines of
the organization to emphasize using only
existing technologies, so that they could
make customer defined time milestones.
Right, so if you're gonna come out and of
course we're going back in time now, but
you know you're coming out with
say 20 megabyte disk drive that
say a consumer a products
company like a Dell.
Or maybe, a disk array firm like
an EMC needs by a certain date,
then you gotta make that date.
And if you're gonna miss that date and not
have those technological specifications
because you were trying to push the edge
of technology, that's unacceptable.
So interestingly, Seagate became much
more responsive on time to market.
But it did so
by focusing on existing technologies.
Meanwhile, simultaneously, in a separate
part of the organization, Steve Luczo and
his team put together Seagate research
which was based back, it's a long story, I
won't tell you all the details and I write
it about in my teaching notes on my blog.
But it was based elsewhere,
it was separate from much of
the organization's production processes.
And that part of the organization
did a lot more blue sky research.
In the fundamentals of material science so
that they were ready to begin to
incorporate solid state memory and
other kinds of memory which we now
see combined with what you'd think
of as traditional disk drives in the much
more hybrid products that you see today.
So there were both of
these efforts going on.
Here at Stanford,
our professor Charles O'Reilly has done
a great deal of research on,
This mixing of the focus on exploiting
what we know and the organizing
to explore what we don't know.
But I have to say that even though
there has been a great deal of work,
especially by professor O'Reilly and
his colleagues on this difficult problem,
it is a problem.
Because after all,
let's go back to that distribution.
Okay.
So if this is this distribution.
Who knows what it's actually shaped like.
Perhaps it's skewed differently.
And down here we have these ideas
that aren't going to work out and
up here we have these ideas
that are going to work out.
In the economy when these
innovations come along,
the economy draws a selection threshold,
okay?
And these firms, these efforts,
these innovations are gonna be deselected.
And the evolutionary process of
the economy leaves us with these
successful firms.
You have to ask yourself, where did
the costs of failure go in the economy?
And the answer in capitalism is that
those costs are what the finance
markets in a sense,
distribute across risk takers,
according to the level of risk
that is seen in these projects.
So, capitalism is actually
reasonably good at allowing for
this kind of an experimentation process.
When you try to explore for
new possibilities inside companies,
in a sense you bring inside
the company these costs.
Which means wide open blue sky
innovation could be cost prohibitive.
I mean to put it another way if you're
gonna, if you really want to win
the lottery you'll by all the lottery
tickets but that's not a, as
business school professors would put it,
positive net present value proposition.
>> Bill, we have a bunch of
questions on that as well and
so if, if you have your research area or
even a group of people who can fail trying
to create that sense that you can fail.
How do you reward the failure?
>> Hm.
Yeah.
Well you know that's a,
it's a tough thing.
And I think one of the ways to look at
the problem is to break the different
techniques of organizing and
leadership into the different parts.
Some are easier to deal with than others.
>> So
let's look at the easiest to deal with and
that would be the sort of architecture and
routines of your organization.
Reporting relationships,
structures, incentives.
Those you can typically manipulate
reasonably easily compared to say,
changing the kind of people
that work in an organization or
changing the culture of an organization,
those are harder to deal with.
So we look at the easier
to deal with techniques,
the organization's structure,
its routines.
There what we see is that
the most innovative organizations
are on the one hand,
structured in a way that they separate
out those who must make the numbers
on a quarter to quarter basis,
from those who are exploring for
new possibilities.
And it's, once again, Charles O'Reilly,
professor Charles O'Reilley's work that
has looked a lot at this separation of
the different parts of what he terms
the ambidextrous organization.
But also then if you look at the different
routines and so for example,
incentive systems which were
implied by your question Deena
there, there, the jury's out.
Incentive systems can
become too complicated.
If I had to boil down what I've
seen in the research so far,
I would say it's not exactly determinate,
but
there is some evidence that incentive
systems that work on behavior rather than
outcome are more forgiving with
respect to failure, right.
So think this through if someone
is your direct report and
they've done what in your
book are the right things
with respect to a process
of innovation but
it hasn't worked out you can reward
them for having gone through the process
of innovating even though in that
particular trial it hasn't worked out.
And we can take a great lesson here
from the world of entrepreneurs.
The big movement now in entrepreneurship
following the work of Eric Reese and
Steve Blank really takes
us back to the old theories
of the great professor James March.
Many of the ideas that I'm talking
about on innovation came out of
James March's work.
And if you had to boil it down this
approach says as follows, and it's written
at, at length by Reese Anblank,
as well as James, March and his students.
If you had to boil it down,
the innovation process comes down to this.
We try something, we find out why it
doesn't work, and then we update.
And you know, for those of you who
studied the scientific method in school,
you know you have your theory which we
are going to call a strategy, and then
you take that, and you test it empirically
as a scientist would in the sciences.
We're going to call that the market or the
customer and than based on what goes wrong
here with the customer,
we update the strategy.
Now if we spend a lot of time
up here in a planning process,
planning the strategy,
we better hope to be right.
Because we put a lot of money into it and
sunk a lot of time.
If instead we minimize how much time we
spend planning and as quickly as possible,
go to the customer,
we learn why we're wrong more quickly and
go through this iterative process of
learning Which as many of our viewers know
has become very popular in Silicon Valley
and leading the startup movement.
And in fact many large
organizations are using
when they engage in Agile
development processes and
other such processes that rely
on iterative improvement.
Now remember,
the secret to iterative improvement
is not getting it right initially.
It's getting a process
of learning in place, so
that we converge over time on a better
solution through trial and error.
Now, there are a lot of problems with
this, and so I'm not saying this is
a panacea, I remember being asked to
speak on this topic to a group of airline
executives in a restaurant that was
overlooking San Francisco Airport.
Which would have been fine, except that
down on the runway was the burned out hull
of the airliner that tragically had,
had a crash landing at San Francisco
Airport here, about a year ago.
And it was very difficult for
me with a straight face to talk about the,
importance of failure and
the need to fail to a bunch of people
in the aeronautics industry overlooking
the burned out hull of an aircraft.
I don't want a lot of foolishness if
someone is running a nuclear powerplant.
There are lots of times we
don't want to see failure.
In fact, if I want a nuclear powerplant,
Ron, I probably want to put Singapore on
the job because we're not
gonna see any foolishness.
So you have to do this kind of approach
to innovation in an appropriate way.
And it may be that a lot of prototyping
and developing goes on behind the scenes.
Before a product is declared ready for
launching as, as a final product.
If you look at the American changes
in the American healthcare system.
It wasn't surprising to a lot of us here
in the Silicon Valley that the initial
rollout of the software to sign up people
for healthcare had a lot of problems.
That's often how software is developed.
It was probably, it was clearly
inappropriate to run the experiment in
real time on the American people While
they were supposed to be signing up for
healthcare.
You really should have gone
through that iterative process of
development in prototypes on
test markets in advance so
that they roll out ends up
being a a much better product.
And yet, when you look at those who
are now retrospectively rationalizing
the flawed rollout of
the healthcare software.
There's a lot of talk about,
couldn't it have been planned better?
No, this wasn't an issue of planning.
It's that the development process for
something really different,
requires lots of iterative learning, and
that wasn't built into that
development process in advance.
>> So, we've had a few questions
on how to finance innovation.
So how much money, is,
is there any research that tells a company
how much they should be spending on people
who aren't really creating anything
that's gonna come to market quickly?
>> Yeah, yeah.
Well, it, it turns out
that it is very difficult for
firms to imitate venture capitalists.
And so, I don't know if the question
really wanted to go at that.
Let me go at that issue though.
So the venture capital community
is a very different approach
to finance than what we see
in many other communities.
One of the prominent venture capital
firms here in Silicon Valley,
for example, had a bit of
a crisis a couple of years ago.
Some of my colleagues were
among their leadership and
I was very interested to hear
how they dealt with the crisis.
They had found they had a real problem
with the failure rate of
their portfolio companies.
The problem was that their
failure rate was going down.
They were becoming concerned
that their access to deal flow,
their view of what was going
on in terms of new venture
creation was perhaps
becoming too conservative.
They were getting not enough foolishness.
Now, that in itself wouldn't
be a problem except that it
might imply they're not
getting enough genius.
And so once again, going back to that
model where you wanna increase variance,
the perspective, the venture community
is of the most successful firms,
is to magnify that variance.
And in, in,
not a, not because you're trying to
make money out of 90% of your ventures.
No, you're only going to be making
money out of a very small proportion of
your ventures.
Now that model works well for
firms that specialize in it and
come to understand the logic of
investing for variance sake.
It does not work so well, the empirical
record shows, for corporations.
For businesses, it's often very difficult
for the internal corporate venturing arm
of business, to in a sense, imitate what
goes on in the venture capital community.
And that empirical fact,
itself, should cause people inside
large corporations to think twice
before they try to play the game
of the venture capitalist.
I think it's much more important for
businesses to have strategic direction,
to understand why they
go to work everyday.
And to try to make good on the investments
that are already in place.
And let me return again to the example
I gave you earlier of Steve Luczo
at Seagate.
For years, ever since solid
state flash memory came along,
people have been worrying about what
would go on with the Winchester and
the disk drive and so forth.
And, and yet, during that period
of great concern, Steve and
his team managed to
continue to make money, and
there have been ups and downs in that
business, as there are in any business.
But they, could not take their eye off
the ball, that they were supplying large
numbers of storage devices to
companies all over the world.
And that is a very different
strategic task than experimenting
in going in new directions.
Do they need to have that
kind of experimentation?
Absolutely, but that doesn't
make them venture capitalists.
The venture capital business
is a very different business.
And I would caution firms that try to
simply imitate the venture capital model.
>> So, going back to
the rewarding failure, you know,
how, how long do you let someone
go on a path of something?
And, and had, but well,
I'll just stop with that.
>> Yeah.
>> How long, how long do you let it go?
And then how do you communicate that
to the rest of the company to, so that
the people in the company who are working
on something that's failing all the time.
Aren't seen as lesser than the people
who are creating the products?
>> Yeah, yeah.
You know, Deena,
this is this is the big question.
This is the million dollar question,
right?
So, let's, let's take a look at
the way that great change comes about.
If this is the performance
of an organization, and
we know these performance
changes over time, right, so
we're gonna have performance
changing over time.
When we're here, in terms of our
performance, if, if we, let's say,
if we stay the course, we would just keep
performance as is, just hypothetically.
But if we move in a new strategic
direction, there's going to be risk,
of course.
But we have a vision of getting to
a much higher level of performance,
by making a strategic change.
The trouble is,
we have to get from here to here.
Right?
We have to somehow get, get up there.
And, and the, the,
the execution of this is not immediate.
Which, Deena, in your question,
is the underlying issue.
Here's what actually happens when
an innovation is successful.
When an inno,
when a big innovation is successful,
it actually makes performance worse,
initially.
Until at some point, and this varies by
context and the nature of the innovation,
we end up improving performance.
And of course,
the exact shape of this curve can vary.
Some people talk about it as the so
called J curve.
It, now this is a problem,
because if we're down here and
you're working at an organization down
there and things have been getting worse.
You're looking at leadership saying,
I'm not sure what you folks are doing, but
things are worse today
than they were yesterday.
And then if leadership stays the course,
they say yeah, but now look,
things are even worse today
than they were yesterday.
And when we talk about leadership,
often, leadership in
a process of innovation has to make clear
the logic of what must be true up here.
Which helps your people understand why
it is that we're having to endure this
difficult process of change
in order to get there.
That's why strategy is important.
Getting back to that iterative learning
process I was describing earlier,
things might not get better as we iterate.
We might be learning about changes we have
to make that are especially difficult.
Lots of end to end solutions that
require the whole system to shift
are very difficult.
I remember when years ago the folks at
Qualcomm were talking about a future,
or when Jacobs, Paul Jacobs and
their team were talking about a future.
Where the wireless system would
move large amounts of data.
Now today, of course, we take that for
granted in the retrospective
rationalization process that I was talking
about earlier But at the time that
Irwin Jacobs, and Paul Jacobs and that
team at Qualcomm were first talking about
that future, there was a tremendous amount
of debate about whether that was true.
In fact, in testifying before the European
regulators, on the subject of whether
the standard that Qualcomm was developing,
so-called CDMA technology, back then.
And, of course, there's been a lot of
technical change since then, but, but
in that debate which is now
a couple of decades ago,
the, European regulators
in fact chose to not allow
CDMA technology into the European system,
because they were unconvinced that
it was going to be effective.
There had been professors here at
Stanford who had engineering professors,
who had published that the ideas
behind Irwin Jacobs' innovation
violated the laws of psychics, so
a tremendous amount of disagreement.
And yet, the folks in the Qualcomm team
remained convinced that although it was
difficult at first, that ultimately
if they could get a system in
place that allowed for
the efficient digitization of data,
that we would be able to do
a tremendous amount of movement of,
of that data among small handheld devices,
which of course, turned out to be true.
But it was much debated for years.
When those systems were, were really
those of you who lived through that
as consumers remember it was hard to get a
phone call, never mind pull up a website,
or make reservations,
all the kinds of things we do today.
Now, we're closer to having
fulfilled that vision, but
getting from here to there
is a very difficult road.
It requires a belief by people in
organizations in their strategy.
It requires leadership that
aims at that end state.
And what's interesting is it doesn't mean
that the leaders know all the details
about what will have to
unfold to get there.
But they know what the end state is, and
they help their people understand
the logic of that business.
>> Wow, I'm just thinking about that
a little bit because there are,
how to communicate that to everyone and
how to be a strong leader is,
sounds very challenging.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Can you talk a little bit about how to,
how you might help the organization
move towards,
I guess having that sort of strategy, and
having that sort of leadership
that can really stay the course?
>> Yeah, that's a good question.
I mean, we've seen it happen in
the form of strong leaders, as you say,
Dina, and
obviously Steve Jobs comes to mind.
When I give leadership lectures
around the world I often
ask the audiences that I face the question
who, what is an example of a great leader?
And one of the things I find so amusing
is that I'll often have military leaders,
religious leaders brought up,
depending on context.
I've had audiences name as their great,
as examples of great leaders Genghis Khan,
Jesus Christ, the prophet Mohammed,
Mahatma Gandhi, Napoleon.
Vladimir Putin was brought up recently.
You can guess where I was.
And, but in almost every situation,
people named Steve Jobs.
And clearly he's seen as the icon for
this kind of visionary leadership.
People used to say that
Steve was surrounded
by a so-called reality distortion field.
Now the point there is,
if Steve believed something was possible,
it often helped others to come to
believe that that was possible.
But here's the problem.
Prior to Steve's fantastic successes
in recent years, before his
tragic and early death, prior to that,
if you go back into the 1990s,
Steve Jobs was often looked at as
an example of bad leadership style.
And it's hard for
us to even imagine that now, but
there were case studies about Steve using
a very dogmatic approach to leadership and
firing people when maybe
that was inappropriate.
Steve's own board unseated him, as people
may know if they've read about the,
the Steve Jobs story.
The, the jury was out, so
if we go back to our J curve, and
if we go back to our J curve, there were
times for Steve when he was down here.
And at that point,
a lot of people had doubts about him.
It's also true that it
wasn't clear that Steve knew
what Apple was going to look
like once it came up here.
What he did do is he put in place
a system that could discover it.
And so, you know,
I think you wanna think about that
in terms of what we do as leaders.
You know, as leaders,
it may be that we don't actually know the
direction the organization needs to go in.
But instead, we want to create
a system that can discover it.
One of the ways I like to,
to help people think about this is to run
through the following thought experiment.
Ask yourself this question.
When you have a good idea, does everybody
have to agree with that idea for
it to be correct?
And most people, if I ask them
that question, will say, well, no.
I'm my own person, you know,
I could come up with an idea and
even if people don't agree with it,
it might be correct.
And yet, when we have an idea, ask
yourself, what's the first thing we do?
We ask people.
We turn to other people, we say,
what do you think of this?
And if the people we ask don't
like the idea, what do we do then?
We often ask someone else.
So what is it we're doing?
On the one hand, we say we don't need to
have everybody agree with us in order for
an idea to be good.
On the other hand, we tend to really
care about what other people think.
Well, here's what I
think's going on there, so
just bear with me as I run through this.
Okay, look.
When we have an idea that's innovative,
we might be right.
But, of course, we might be wrong, and
the more interesting the idea, the less
we can know in advance which is which.
Or to put it another way,
if we know in advance,
we have enough information to know
the difference between genius and
foolishness, the idea
isn't that innovative.
But what we can detect right away is
whether or not people agree with us.
If we ask other people and
they're all agreeing with us,
we've got ourselves a consensus idea.
If we ask other people and
there's a lot of debate and a lot of
the people that we ask do not agree,
let's call that a non-consensus idea.
Okay, so look at the situation we're in.
What we can observe?
We can observe whether people agree,
or whether they, they don't agree.
What do we wish we could observe?
We wish we could observe whether
we're right or whether we're wrong,
and we can't tell.
Now, for sake of discussion,
let's imagine we're right.
Where would you rather be
if you knew you were right?
Well, if you think that through,
look back at that Irwin Jacobs story.
You want to be non-consensus.
Cuz if you're right and people are saying
you're violating the laws of physics,
in the end, you're gonna own
all the intellectual property.
You're gonna have a tremendous advantage
and, in fact, when you hear of
the tremendous amount of intellectual
property payments that go to Qualcomm.
Those were earned by that firm being in
the right non-consensus box early on.
If everyone already agreed with us,
we'd all be right.
That's fine.
It's just not as profitable as being
right in a non-consensus sense.
But Deena, now look at this.
What if we're wrong?
If we're wrong,
where do you wanna be then?
And there is no doubt.
If you're wrong, you just don't wanna be
alone, because nobody wants to be here.
This is the fool.
And a big problem we face in trying
to manage innovation is that
the fear of being a fool is often much
stronger than the hope of being a genius.
Because of that, odds are people
in your organization have ideas
that they are afraid to come forward with.
People will side to consensus thinking,
even though they might
have brilliant ideas.
And the question you have to ask yourself
as a leader is that have you created
an environment in your organization where
it's safe for people to risk being a fool.
And if the answer to that is no,
you are not going to hear the ideas
that potentially are genius.
>> Wow.
Again, can't help thinking about how you,
how you know on the J cur,
but how you know if
you are actually on the J curve versus
just heading towards a failure.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And how,
ow you help people who don't like change.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> So again, you're heading in this path.
You're trying to help people fail,
and you're trying to find the genius.
And you're surrounded by people who want
results and who don't, sort of, I guess,
honor or respect the failure.
So, how do you help that?
That, the fool.
>> Yeah.
Yeah, you know, it's, it's,
constantly around the business school
Deena, we hear people saying, you know,
I've come here to learn about
best business practice.
Or we've come here to understand how to
interpret the evidence we're getting in
our quarterly results.
We're very inductive from data that way.
We wanna see the results.
How do I, how can I tell?
How can I model this?
How can I know?
If the idea is really innovative,
you can't know with respect to
the experience of the firm.
There is risk.
That's unavoidable.
What we can do in advance
is elaborate on our logic.
The Stanford Business School in our
new curriculum has focused greatly
on helping our students think
logically about strategy.
The reason we did this is that the, the,
what leadership can do is offer an,
a logic for
where it is the firm wants to go.
Now, that logic can have flaws and
will need to be updated in
an iterative way as evidence comes in.
But the nature of innovation is that
if the innovation is big enough,
we don't have the data now to know.
We didn't have the data in 1990
to know how we would look at
the World Wide Web by 2000.
We didn't have the data when they were
first making social network sites to
realize that they would be platforms for
sharing pictures within ten
years of their founding.
And we can go through example after
example such as we've done over this,
the course of this webinar.
But what we did have,
was the capacity to engage in logic,
and it is a primary job for
leadership to help their people
understand the logic of the business.
The strategy is a retrospective
rationalization of what we've done as
a firm but it is also a roadmap for
the logic that should get
us through the J-curve.
Are we going to be right?
Of course not, in fact,
we need to build failure
into the system as we discover
our way through the J-curve.
But without leadership and logic,
if all we're relying on are short
term results, we're never going
to take the kind of risk that gets us to
that much higher level of innovation.
>> That's great.
You know, I want to just mention that
if we were in one of your programs,
which I highly recommend
people would have time to ask you
questions throughout the presentation.
But also to talk with you on breaks and
at meal times.
And so, we have a lot of questions that
we're not gonna be able to get to.
But, I just wanna make sure
that everybody's aware that,
that in our programs it, you get to
continue the conversation, both,
with the faculty member and
with the, the cohort.
And so, we don't have a huge amount of
time left and there are a lot of things
that you've said that I, I wanna make
sure that we repeat and get out.
And so if you could just come back to
sort of the communicating failures.
>> Mm, mm-hm.
>> I mean, I think you've touched on
the strategy which is really wonderful.
But maybe we could just end with
how you communicate the failures so
that everybody doesn't,
doesn't make the same mistake again, or
that maybe someone else can
find that path and move on?
>> Yeah, you know, it's a,
it's a difficult thing and I brought up
the example of Qualcomm before and
I'd like to raise it again as an example.
The chief learning officer at Qualcomm's
a, a woman named Tamar Elkeles and
has provided, I think, a lot of us with
a tremendous example with how to deal
with the question that you asked, Deena.
It's been a very successful company,
she's been their chief
learning officer for years.
What's interesting is as a c level
officer right there with top management,
she's been really pushing
on the innovation process.
And in particular,
when you come to be a Qualcomm employee,
like every firm, you go through
an initial process of orientation.
What's interesting at Qualcomm is that
you will, you will hear films, and
many of those films are top-level Qualcomm
leaders talking about
their greatest failures.
And you know, from the beginning,
they focus on the fact that well-intended
behavior that leads to failing
outcomes have very good implications.
Obviously, you don't want behaviors
that are against policy or
in some way, nefarious.
That's not what we're getting at.
But we're talking about people trying to
do their job where there's a inherent
element of risk and things don't go well.
If that's a career-ending event, people
throughout an organization know that.
And they get very conservative, and the,
the great innovative organizations of
the world try to create a culture where in
some contexts, it's safe to be innovative.